it is literally flooding in here it's a
flood it's a flood it's post-apocalyptic
I think it works pretty well you know
what it's on theme I reckon so I think
they planned it how are you feeling
tonight we are finally here
I'm terrified but I'm excited I'm so
excited I'm so overwhelmed it was such
like a phenomenal experience for me so
it's crazy that it's like it's all
coming to her head tonight would you say
to fans that are about to get their
hearts ripped out for nine weeks
straight yeah get ready you better know
what you're letting yourself in for
because you're right your hearts are
going to get ripped from there from
there
the wood ripped from there hold on from
their chest right that'll do okay yeah
we got there now I've been asking
everyone to do the clicker noise but
everyone was like well yes everyone's
like Bella does it the best I do
you ready should I be a Clickety yes
this is terrible but the noise wait
okay that's it perfect maybe it's more
like a dolphin I think it's maybe too
nice to be a clicker like uh
thank you so much
[Music]